Welcome back everyone
Is Charlie
Marvel just killed off Ms Marvel,
even though she's going to be in the live
action Marvel movie later this year.
And they have big plans for the character
they're making Ms Marvel season
two on Disney Plus as well.
They've been doing way more
with the characters than ever before,
just in general.
naturally, everybody was surprised
when they just flat out
killed the character with no warning.
and it's all part of working
around the grand tradition of comic book
continuity problems
in the most extreme ways possible.
So all explained what's going on
You have questions?
Yes, I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions.
But rest assured,
we're going to answer them right now.
because spoiler,
really seems like Marvel's bending over
backwards to take some continuity issues.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're in the middle of Secret Invasion
episodes.
There are only a couple left
that's going to help set up the Marvel's
movie that's happening later this year.
And we're going to get the next
big Marvel's trailer
in the next couple of weeks
in lieu of Marvel doing a big Comic-Con
panel in Hall H, where they typically drop
a bunch of footage Everybody's seen
the news about the big strike
that's going on right now.
Most big studios have canceled their huge
Comic-Con plans for movies and TV shows.
There's still stuff happening at
Comic-Con, just not nearly as much.
So I will be doing a bunch of Comic-Con
videos
for all the stuff that does get released.
but you probably saw recently that Marvel
just killed off the Kamala Khan. Ms..
Marvel character
in Amazing Spiderman number 26.
So they killed her off in a completely
different characters title.
She teams up with Spider-Man
to stop the emissary from killing
Mary-Jane Watson to become a guy
At one point, Spider-Man task.
Ms Marvel was keeping him away from Mary
Jane, or else Earth ends. Ms..
Marvel comes up with the idea
to distract him
while Mary Jane runs away down an alley,
and he winds up teleporting in front of
Mary Jane and teleporting behind Ms..
Marvel and running a blade through her
back, literally killing the character off
by having her getting stabbed in the back
in a dark alleyway R.I.P.
to Kamala Khan. Ms..
Marvel people went crazy,
Even though we knew
there was going to be a big comic
book twist.
What was the country like?
You can trust you can trust this girl.
She might be a Skrull.
Come on, this girl.
Right after they released that issue,
they had a comic for her funeral
called Fallen Friend.
The Death of Ms..
Marvel, very reminiscent of the classic
death of Superman storyline, Funeral
for a friend, all the Marvel characters
coming to mourn her Again,
people still wondering
why Marvel would kill off the character
who they've been trying
to make such a high profile person
in the movies in the Disney
Plus series right now,
Marvel's even having her help put together
the next young Avengers team in the MCU.
They had big plans for the character.
this is where we get to the old school
comic book twists,
like the biggest of comic book twists
they didn't feature or anything like that.
But anyone who has ever read a comic book
ever knows that there is no such thing
as perma death in the comics.
Even the super old characters
who actually did get fringed back
in the day have since been retconned back
into more modern comics No.
I'm already lying.
And Marvel literally
just confirmed my theory.
A lot of other people's theories this past
week with a bunch of new preview pages.
Marvel killed her off so that they could
resurrect her as a mutant in.
A lot of you
who don't read comics regularly are like,
Wait a minute, this seems complicated.
Why would they do that?
What's the whole point
in the new preview, Iman Vellani,
the actress who plays Kamala Khan. Ms..
Marvel in real life,
helped write on a new comic book for her,
where she gets resurrected
as a mutant called Ms..
Marvel, the new mutant.
The title is a reference
to the New Mutants
comic book as well as you see her
wearing a new X-Men variant of her Ms..
Marvel suit based on the original X-Men
comic book suits from the 1960s.
the official synopsis reads, After being
brought back the Infraco and resurrection
technology, Kamala is shocked to learn
she is a mutant.
But before she has a chance
to come to terms with this revelation,
the catastrophic fall of X
will throw her world into chaos
and a secret mission on behalf of the
X-Men Fall of X is a big X-Men storyline.
This happening
in the current Marvel Comics right now,
so they're making her a big part of the
ongoing X-Men storyline and present day
last month when they killed her off,
a lot of us suspected
that Marvel would just resurrect her
using Krakoa or something similar
and say that she'd always had mutant DNA
inside of her.
Krakoa is a living
mutant island would detect it
and bring her back The island
has the mutant powers of resurrection.
But only mutants
are allowed on the island.
So it's like Marvel's way of saying that
she'd always secretly been a mutant,
not an inhuman.
now the people who created the characters,
they are completely retconning
the inhuman stuff out of her back story.
She will have been inhuman for a while
and there'll be
some big twist that will explain
why she's a mutant now. But.
A lot of people are like,
why bend over backwards this far?
Marvel will eventually do more Inhumans
related stuff in the MCU, like Anson
Mount, who plays Black Bolt, came back in
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
even though they killed them off
pretty quickly, said
that he's already been talking to Marvel
about coming back as another version
of his black Bolt character.
Marvel's eventually going to bring Chloe
Bennet's quake back in.
She's probably still going to be
an inhuman the whole Ms..
Marvel Kamala Khan mutant thing actually
goes way back to the original creation
of the character and gets into the whole
like Perlmutter versus Kevin Feige,
the X-Men movies
copyright issue way back from the early
2000s, the Kamala Khan
character was created in 2013.
At the time, Fox still owned all the X-Men
Fantastic Four movie rights,
and since the early 2000,
after Marvel had to sell off the rights
to its characters, Ike Perlmutter,
who eventually came
to control the company after Marvel
went into bankruptcy in the nineties, made
all the comic book people stop publishing
new X-Men in Fantastic Four comics
because Marvel didn't own the movie
rights anymore.
He didn't want them
promoting some other studio's movies in
Fox that just started making all
the original X-Men Fantastic Four movies.
through the 2000, the 20 tens.
There were still X-Men
comics that they did, but very few
compared to the emphasis on them
before the sell off.
look.
The X-Men characters used to be Marvel's
most popular group in the nineties.
that's why Fox bought the rights
back in the nineties
because they felt like they could develop
a movie based on the X-Men
because it was so commercial at the time.
It was so popular just in general.
so when they created
the Kamala Khan character in the 20
tens, the creators at the time
wanted to make her a mutant
but because of the copyright in the movie
stuff going on,
the Marvel editors forced them
to make her an inhuman instead.
So they always had planned
on making her a mutant.
They just weren't allowed to
because of copyright reasons.
Remember how several years ago
Ike Perlmutter made Kevin big?
You start developing an Inhumans movie.
We saw it up on the board at Comic-Con
one year.
All those inhuman plans.
It seemed like Marvel was making was
because they couldn't get the X-Men rights
back at the time, and they wanted a group
to replace the X-Men.
obviously things are way different
in present day now.
Disney bought Fox,
they're doing Deadpool three,
like I just did a Deadpool
three video of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
fighting Ryan Reynolds, Deadpool,
all those original X-Men
Fantastic Four actors, even Ben Affleck's
Daredevil is coming back in.
Deadpool
three is their versions of the characters.
but. Through all this, Ms..
Marvel continued
being an inhuman character in the comics.
So when Kevin finally did the Ms..
Marvel series after they got the X-Men
rights back in the finale,
they had a big teaser for Secretly
Being a Mutant and even played
the X-Men, the animated series theme
song at the time.
A lot of people just assumed that
that meant
that she would be a mutant in the MCU
and she just keeping an Inhuman
in the comics.
Now, based on the death and rebirth
twist here, it seems like they're
just changing the character in the comics
so that the comic book version and the MCU
version are a little bit closer.
there's still a billion differences
between the comic book version
in the MCU version.
It's the same
for all the different characters,
like even Iron Man,
all the regular MCU characters.
But now and present day is is them doing
the things that they always wanted to do
because now they have all the rights.
There aren't any behind
the scenes issues going on preventing them
from saying that she's a mutant.
like I said this twist is probably
one of the most comic booky
things that they can do.
Like, okay, we're going to explain
how we're going
to completely change the character
and it's totally going to make sense.
Marvel hasn't said
when they're going to release Ms..
Marvel Season two.
She's going to be in the Marvel's
movie later this year, enduring
that maybe like in a post-credits scene,
she's going to steal some of Nick
Fury's information
from his saber space station that has data
on other superpowered individuals.
Nick Fury has been evaluating
for potential use, quote unquote.
remember, he's
putting together that next Avengers team,
so he's making a list and checking it
twice.
One eyed
F-bomb dropping Santa Claus in fun fact,
Santa Claus is also a super powerful
Marvel character.
He even wielded the Infinity Gantlet,
showed up in the X-Men comics a bunch Miz
Marvel is supposed to steal Nick
Fury's list and then go around trying
to recruit younger characters
to make their own team, so to speak.
There will be the young Avengers
characters like Cassie Lang Stinger, Kate
Bishop, Hawkeye, eventually building
in Tommy once they come back as teenagers.
Older Billy, we know, is
supposed to be played by Joe Locke.
He's going to show up in the Agatha
Coven of Chaos series.
I'm not sure where Tommy is coming back.
Maybe.
During the upcoming Vision Quest series.
there will be more young Avengers Easter
eggs in the next few years, and we'll see
if the full team comes together before
or after Avengers five and Avengers six.
They might wait a little while
to do the actual full team
like Hawking is supposed to show up
at some point too.
He'll be on the team once he does appear.
We'll see if they wind up
doing a version of Iron Lad or
they just substitute Riri Williams
Ironheart onto the team instead.
Young T'Challa Junior is also
so much younger than the other characters.
The only way that he'd make it onto
the team is they aged him up super fast.
Some big twists in Avengers
five or Avengers six.
Right.
Now, I'm not expecting him
to become the next Black Panther
until after Black Panther three.
I do think they'll do at least one more.
Shuri Black Panther movie
then wait three or four years
and have young T'Challa take the mantle
and by that time he be almost old enough
even without having to age him up in some
big twist
behind the scenes that new Marvels trailer
should release in the next week or two.
I'll do new video for it when it comes
and I'll put a link
for the last big Marvels trailer
in the description below.
Everyone click here for my Deadpool
3 Wolverine video
and click here for my Secret Invasion
Episode 5 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!